et tout le monde sait ce quiz iwuy cette
intro et intérêts par loi française
depuis 2011
tu as well as computer respectent pas la
loi aujourd'hui on se trouve non pas sur
un jeu mais on se retrouve sur youtube
voilà on fait une vidéo sur youtube sur
youtube le chichon j'ai envie de faire
ça parce que récemment j'y repense un
petit peu vidéo qu'on faisait à l'époque
et je me suis dit que [ __ ] on a bien
évolué et on a grandit aussi en a même
pris un petit pot de barbe et où la
toute première vidéo de la chaîne la
qualité avant tout rendez-vous ensuite à
celle que j'avais fait des délires d'un
trou avec une vidéo commentée par
complètement au cou il est absolument
scandaleux c'est un scoop de vidéos
comme entête de la whey cry 2
en somme je vais pas très à l'aise j'ai
pas bien ça dure une veste ferai pas je
ne veux pas les sectes la démo donc
c'est dieu aurait eu un petit stress
dans la voile je reconnais je vais même
bac au magnifique où ils sont vraiment
bien géré c'est vraiment vraiment beau
donc là il ya un petit ennemis qui nous
a fait un joli saut excellent football
propre gueule c'est génial mais par
contre les pouvoirs prennent de
l'énergie donc allier la barre en bas à
droite mais façon dont elle
s'intéressait [ __ ] c'est scandaleux à
l'idée aussi vente
[Musique]
on voit le pas de mec qui va les arrêter
la caméra quoi et là on était sur un
nuage cloud sous cette double à corte où
là il s'est passé quoi elle vous
expliquer ce que je pense du jeu mais
j'étais tout le temps blasé quoi c'est
incroyable écouter cet homme blasé sont
vraiment papa super quoi on nous avait
promis chômage mais non on nous avait
promis un bain j'ai appris que barney
pour faire jouer personnellement je vois
vraiment pas ce cas là ça fait super
bizarre deschamps cette vidéo montrent à
quoi s était à 3 au 5 mars 2011
ça fait bientôt quatre ans vous rendez
compte comment s'entraîner au snack
version blackhawks salut tout le monde
le sait squeeze et on se retrouve
aujourd'hui pour une nouvelle vidéo
comme vous voulez nous sur call of duty
black ops c'est pourquoi je n'aime plus
modern warfare 2 mais on s'en fiche on
nouvelle a trop nouvelle intro l'homme
qui change et un trou tous les deux
jours alors ça alors ça c'est pas du
tout moi qui l'ait fait êtes vous déçu
moi oui c'est tout le monde sait squeeze
ils se retrouvent aujourd'hui pour une
nouvelle vidéo sur call of duty et je
mets bien fermer un trois points comme
ça salut tout le monde
on se retrouve aujourd'hui pour une
nouvelle vidéo sur modern moi super
chiant en claquant je me suis vite et
c'était super chiant j'ai fait du
minecraft le 13 avril 2011 première
vidéo bonus donc louisiane 200 abonnés
sur minecraft en bon français je le
rappelle la glace je fais toujours cette
blague donc ça fait quatre ans j'en ai
mais j'étais toujours blasé encore une
fois y'a pas à les différents kg sniper
et tutorial là qu'est ce que j'ai fait
salut tout le monde si on va mettre un
détecteur est belle celle là sachez-le
fait moi même mais je pense que ça se
voit là on commet pas ce qui se passe et
on va dans le le titanic ont tiré juste
après on met un couteau de lancer on
regarde au ralenti et la séquence
bon ben voila je vous fais tu es bordel
plus tard c'était une super blague
l union de projets à taille ta musique
de merde donc ensuite le drague
attendant plus c'est plein de tutos mais
mois d'après mes souvenirs je dis juste
de make up une nulle au monde à call of
quoi mais je les écoutais tuto pour
apprendre rejoint être nulle peut-être
donc presque deux mois après après la
vidéo je me montre enfin une vidéo
surprise bédiala 282000 vue donc je
pense que vous êtes des petits coquins
parce que je pense qu'entre temps il ya
plein de gens qui sont allés se fout de
ma gueule bord des pièces avec une
montée bon aux cultures et avoue jean et
j'étais soufflé que j'étais cargo est ce
que j'ai peur de montrer stellardo
non je rigole à champions champions
champions mais douchez ont quitté la
pièce depuis début de cette vidéo je
crois qu'ils aiment pas du tout et dans
cette vidéo
cette vidéo cette coupe comme ça tout à
fait je sens un peu gêné l'accord bah
oui on va donc diriger un cheveu sur la
langue mais c'est la manière donc voilà
l'appareil photo de ma maman était
extrêmement nul et attend des sujets tv
il à l'époque s'il vous plaît qui m'ont
dit que j'étais un gros naze que je
volais les vidéos des autres qui est
touchant la colère donc je m'explique
c'est ouais énerver les fâcher
wolfenstein enemy territory chez
l'impact qui a fait une vidéo là dessus
[Musique]
oh hey hey hey hey lalala
ça
là j'avais passé cinq heures et demie à
la faire en suivant un tutoriel image
par image
oh [ __ ] mais j'ai eu combien tu es un
troll à chaque nouvelle vidéo j'avais
une nouvelle intro c'est incroyable
actuellement j'en ai plus donc je pense
que oui voilà il ya une raison j'ai un
mot tu viens voir ma nouvelle vidéo si
c'est ça vient de monter dessus mes
anciennes vidéos par une nouvelle pardon
pas pourquoi tu repars voilà je vois que
c'est une vue n'est pas une vidéo où je
jouais quand même temps moi ma tête en
bas donc écouter ces partis franchement
je n'aime vraiment pas ce genre de jeux
à bas pourtant mon gars tu sais pas ce
qui t'attend tu m'as offert pendant
trois ans encore dit [ __ ] de jeu de
roi et j'avais donc j'avais 14 15 ans et
je flippais vendu trahissent [ __ ] rien
valait vraiment le fameux [ __ ] qui
sort 600 fois chaque vidéo maintenant
[Musique]
c'est pas moi oh oh oh oh je me touchent
les lobes comme si ça pouvait me
soulager louis à l'acheter de retour de
colonies c'est ce que je suis aux anges
j'ai carrément revanche je suis
vachement gamme qui souhaitent être
exportée dans quoi la dent du jaune
d'oeuf au delà c'était le début des
défis de squeeze s'il vous plaît j'étais
avec un pote et à chaque fois que je
mourrais mettez une claque
jonathan c'est bien ce que je vous
prenez quand même épisode cas du député
squeeze on dirait les miniatures de
cyprien avec l'écriture comme ça qui est
je crois qu'ils savaient police
d'écriture et où medi dont lulu c'est
pas bien ce que tu as fait 5h04 cradle à
chaque mort mon pote m'écrase 1,9 sur un
an mais qu'est-ce que j'étais con olala
c'est dégueulasse tonga ohlala oh mon
premier podcast sur les toilettes
c'est mignon tout plein combat comédiens
comédiens français mon prochain film de
luc besson l'a juste une danse / j'avais
fait ça sur les toilettes est ce qui est
drôle c'est que norman a sorti a pas si
longtemps que ça paraît une vidéo sur
les toilettes
j'avais vu dans le futur à l'époque on
naît le 9 novembre 2011
je n'avais encore marc des colosses
situant des vidéos sur call of duty et
est toujours aussi nul
y en a marre des connexions merde y en a
marre des mecs icade tout le temps y en
a marre des bombardiers furtifs y en a
marre de la rage constants ah oui nos
bateaux mais lui tu vas une vidéo sur
call of duty 6 si tu en as marre à ce
point tu supprimes le jeu et tu fais de
vidéos sur a dit boucher pas c'est là
qu'on a fait des chansons avec feydeau à
l'époque on avait fait ma journée d'un
geek externe va tomber j'ai raté sa voix
la journée d'un geek la presse chansons
qu'on a fait avec fais aurait fait
plusieurs chansons comme ça eh ben mon
gars dont 6 passes pas moi qui chante et
non mais vous avez peur dans la vidéo
récente de karaoké parti que sinon tu
vas avoir du français ensuite des
mathématiques et tu auras brawn la
classe à ce que ça va je me souviens
plus la première vidéo sur un jeu indé
la frayeur au 8 août à allah je me suis
bien tu là il ya divers vidéo notamment
sur just dance 2 just under aussi avec
gwen à l'époque aux ag c'est vrai
[ __ ] à l'époque encore plus
maintenant au c'est quoi ça ce quils san
ace un énorme dossier
j'ai peur de cliquer savez vous au moins
vous êtes content d'avoir cliqué cette
vidéo vous tombez sur une vidéo excusé
mais moi je sais plus ce que c'est bon
sweethearts doit être usée orelsan du
jackpot quand j'arrive dans la cession
comme on soupire catherine
les années début 2000 nouvelles
générations ce disque on était fous
parce qu'on découvre alors qu'ils sont
on ne peut pas ce moelleux chromite
utilise plus de taux n'est qu'au lit les
vidéos sur l'album série m c'est quoi ce
truc de merde j'ai jamais eu aussi mal à
l'aise en voyant encore plus tard vous
tapez une barre va pas du tout alors
être mal à l'aise comme moi tellement
c'est horrible put inde il ya des vidéos
qui sont tellement malsaine que tu
rigole pas t'es juste mal à l'aise
devant ça devait être l'intro du nouveau
défi de squeeze puis ça faisait super
longtemps que je n'avais pas fait et là
je voulais un petit peu marquer le coup
en faisant une intro assez cool et je
mets des prix pour un rappeur quoi là je
regarde ne pas voir que tu es ce moment
montage je peux encore le faire alors je
dis ça mais bon ne me faites pas
regretter [ __ ] bon et bien voilà les
gens je crois qu'on a fait le tour a
aidé à écouter cela fait chaud au coeur
de voir tout c'est dans ces deux vidéos
ça m'a rappelé et plein de bons
souvenirs pleins de belles choses
en tout cas merci de me suivre tous les
jours ça me fait vraiment chaud cas je
vous jure lâché tout et me voilà le
squeeze musqui ému merci d'avoir gardé
jusqu'à vidéo continueront vous plaire
surtout mon pis vous êtes temps
[Musique]